Gregg yeah you and I let's go see a game
we sure did
what game is that that's the last of us
part two finally whoa this is the
yesterday yesterday yeah it feels it's
been a blur yeah
I've been up it for the past couple days
so I'm exhausted but anyway we saw the
last of us too we got to play about two
hours of the last us two in LA overall
impressions man based on what you played
man cyberpunk is gonna have to bring
everything in the video game universe to
stop this game yeah this game I I've
talked to no one else about it so I'm
very interested of a conversation well I
mean somebody's played it right yeah we
talked about it literally let me
rephrase I haven't talked to somebody
who's not a [ __ ] but yeah like I it
like it floored me on just about every
level and I think that's saying
something as blast of us is amazing we
all know the last of us is amazing so
you assume last was part two will be
amazing and getting in there and from
the fidelity of how it looks from how it
runs from me being on a horse in snow
walking up to a rare red dead - I know
hey guess what it's fun to ride this
horse riding over to a random evergreen
tree that's not on the critical path in
bumping into it watching like it
dynamically move and snowfall off of it
like oh my god and then like you know
the demos are split in two very
different ways right where we did the
initial one which was patrol and then
the next one which was suburbs Patrol
being in the winter the day after or
yeah the morning after the ìiî barn
scene where they kissed for the first
time and then suburbs being I'm guessing
so it's in the Seattle suburbs set seems
like summer that seems like this summer
time everything was overgrown you're in
shorts and it's very hot looking it was
both the fact that like the cold made me
feel cold and it made me think about
like the way they do crunching snow
sounds and breaking ice sounds and
little things like that
- let alone the snow storm you get
caught in then suburbs being that hot
thing but from the first part being
basically all about story and being like
the narrative story driven let's just
talk game I love and like hearing about
what Joel and Ellie are literally up to
on a daily basis and who
you know I'm who Dina is in this whole
relationship and finding her out too
then jumping to the combat and the
combat I honestly feel and grant that
I'm coming off it and I'm high often
right now but I do feel the most intense
combat I've ever had in a video game
like what my heart pounding in my chest
like everything was a scrap that I could
have gone either way every time like
Ellie's on the ground and I've just shot
something or jumped on a dog and stabbed
in the neck a million times to kill it
like it was that moment of her bandaging
and breathing and me bandage me
breathing try to figure out what to
happen next
I I walked away after that second demo
shaking like I like the adrenaline was
going through me and I remember after I
finished it I just sat there for a
little bit and I walked over and I like
could not sit down I just kept walking
around and then I finally sat down and
Neil druckmann walked over and he's like
it was fun watching you play and I was
like you know Druckman said it was fun
watching me play I couldn't say anything
cuz I was still like just like so tense
it's just like thank you and I was just
like processing it all
but a little background - I played the
hell out of the first one I didn't get
the Platinum because bad review was bad
we can all admit it I got stuck on the
one where it's like you got to have a
conversation you gotta have those like
optional conversations did you do all
the multiplayer stuff I did most of the
multiplayer I was I think for me where
it's like you can play for after in game
it was like a certain amount of days
it's like you played 20 days not in real
time but really a long time in fail and
it's over and then you know yeah but but
yeah so I played the first one many
times I played it on grounded mode so I
am very excited for this game and I was
definitely blown away it's more Last of
Us right like I think you know I
wouldn't say last this was divisive but
there were definitely people out there
who just like it was too dark for them
it was too much I know people who didn't
like it because they thought Joel's a
bad character like I've heard lots of
different opinions like the last of his
one of my lifes like in my top 5 games
of all time I don't really love that
game I there are people I really whose
opinions I really respect you don't like
it not because of the tone but because
they don't think that writing is good
like valid but I'm also like it's gonna
be so good yeah I agree with the like
for me it was full spoilers for Last of
Us
when the last of us ends and you're in
the hospital and the doctor pulls the
scalpel on you and there I would I
remember waiting for the choice to pop
up and he's gonna be are you gonna save
her or you gonna let this happen and
then I got stabbed in the neck and
killed and I was like I have to do this
and I went in there I remember shooting
and it all happened and I remember I put
down the phone and I texted my friend at
Naughty Dog and I was just like I'm the
bad guy he's like well are you the bad
guy and I meet y'all Isabella Jill's not
bad I make Jules a bag and it was like
that thing of I didn't like that in
terms of my own further but I loved this
story and I love that they unflinchingly
told me a story that like here this is
what we're telling you this isn't
choose-your-own-adventure we're telling
you exactly what happened I counted as
one of my like favorite video game
endings to like like I'm there with like
red like red at one I really think it's
strong they stick that landing I like
that you don't have the option I I don't
know I really think the writing is is
really strong I I don't know I'm yeah so
we'll get back to Les Mis 2 in a second
but did you also know that you don't
have to shoot the doctors in there well
I mean something that you do it I got
stabbed for sure I just scare him with
the gun yeah you can scare him away so I
I kicked open the door and I was like
you're not touching her and and shot all
of them and then I did it again and it
was like oh you can just walk up and
take her and they just kind of back off
and let you really you have a choice in
that but like you you still you know
still no longer I was like I would save
humanity I'm sorry but yeah so so
playing The Last of Us 2 and that combat
system like you were saying is is the is
so intense like like all the animations
the way the noises Ellie makes like when
you kill an enemy you hear them shout
that person's name that was the thing
dude like well now when you shoot
somebody like they are when you
kill the dogs they were calling up the
dog's name yeah it was like wow what a
great [ __ ] plan scheme totally and
like the combat especially for what they
were talking about right like I'm sure
you got the we weren't the same session
right I don't know mine was more so is
that thing I'm sure you're the same
session from Neil coming up there and
talking about like you know this is the
biggest in terms of scope and scale and
story and everything we've done right
and I didn't understand what they meant
and when he started going through all
the different stuff of like Ellie's more
athletic than Jules so she is a
dedicated jump button she has a
dedicated dodge button like she can move
around more like oh that's cloud owners
to inland playing the game and seeing it
all in action in this suburbs part where
it was fighting people it all made sense
for me of like cool like I'm dodging
around now while you're trying to stab
me you can dodge also shoot if somebody
trying to shoot you you dodge around
it's harder for you get shot you know
jumping on a thing sure but it was the
scale part of the dogs when they're out
there will pick up on your scent so you
have to throw stuff to distract them and
then you can run up and knife them and
that's how I did it you could shoot them
and do a bunch different stuff but
inevitably since I'm playing this for
the first time and these are all
mechanics I have introduced everything
turns into a crap show right it's like I
run up and stab the dog so the guy
notices so I shoot him and something I
throw him off but it was that idea that
I broke you know the first time when it
went and fubar I ran into the house and
then out the back door and then into the
other house and then out the window and
it was like oh this Maps huge in terms
of like I can actually go and get lost
like literally nothing in the way that
you know how games have always done that
before like lose your attackers wherever
this one was you could easily see like
they'd come to where they had seen me
and then it was suddenly I was in
control now like who I've lured to view
this way how am I going to take you out
and how am I gonna use it against you
yeah evolution like from the sounds of
it sounds like less of an evolution of
the Last of Us and more like an
evolution of what they were doing with
Lost legacy in the way then you could
dip in and out of stealth
yeah like the bigger boxer yeah exactly
exactly no that makes sense yeah least
what we played is still tighter than
lost legacy like it's not as open but to
your point like one thing I noticed was
that like like Ellie's agility feeds
into that more open level design because
you never really felt trapped in a
corner and that was one thing in the
first Last of Us game where the this is
this is the route you're taking you're
gonna have to fight these people sure
you
maybe go right or left or whatever and
if you get caught you're probably just
gonna get back to the corner and this I
never felt trapped someone would notice
me and I'd look behind me I'd see a
window I could hop out of and because I
was le because the map design the level
design was more open I could hop out
that window I could run back there I
could lay on the ground crawl under a
car or something like that and wait it
out but you couldn't stay there too long
because the dogs are constantly sniffing
you out like if they basically if you
pull up your listen mode you can see the
scent you leave behind and if a dog
intersects with that scent then that dog
will just follow that path until it gets
to you unless you can break that sense
somehow so you're kind of forced to
constantly move and I think that all
feeds into Ellie being more agile the
levels being more open and it just it
really embraces that sort of hit and run
tactics and that was the thing is like
once it started it was like it's go time
and it's what you're talking about of
the intensity of it right where I like
my heart pounding your adrenaline where
it was that you know in the last of us
one it felt like they were almost
puzzles in terms of what the order I
should be to take people out how okay
cool
and if you screwed it up you're gonna
die and you're gonna redo it and this
one was the opposite of that where it
was like it felt real in a way of I'm
actually engaging with these people and
what I've caught them off-guard they've
caught me off-guard what's going to
happen there was one where you know I
was thinking I think it was a bookstore
and then I went in the glass room and
then people came in and it was like
three groups and I waited and waited and
the dude came around I stabbed his dog
and he freaked out and they started
screaming and running in and then I
jumped up and I dodged her on a bunch
stabbed him got shot a bunch the drop
down got the shotgun shot her then they
heard the commotion they came in like
there's this new thing of when there's
cracks in the wall or well things you
can squeeze past pushing forward and
hitting axe and then you squeeze through
and the other people do it too so this
other person came in and I managing
myself and I'm great and like I was
cycling through my weapons I was using
everything I had they you know most
times when games give me traps something
to set to booby trap I'm always like I
will never use this this was the thing
of like okay well I'm gonna put it in
the grass and the dog will come get me
but it'll blow up them but then they'll
know and it's like it was just as
ever-evolving how am I gonna tackle the
situation get out of this agendize get
to fight infected yeah the first part so
the Patrol is Dena and Ellie out
only four infected through these
different things and they have all these
different checkpoints you go into and
write in a logbook that you've done it
and eventually yeah it basically we
played all the stuff you saw from the
trailer so they go in to investigate and
that part where Ellie falls through the
roof
and lands out there that's where you
pick up that's your first set of
infected and that was you know fun
learning the ropes again with them
because it's been so long on my plan so
can they see me I forget though they
don't see me okay cool but then there's
these new giant dudes that explode and
poison you and it was the next question
away is there different infected and did
it feel different fighting them here
than it did in the first last of us it
felt I think this time around again more
empowering you don't I mean to get in
there and realize of course that they're
not the biggest threat like you know
man's inhumanity to man is these guys
are dumb idiots that I can get around
and do it but then it was the thing of
like oh that one is brand-new and I try
to treat it like the other ones and they
just exploded and poisoned me it was the
same thing from that would happen in the
suburbs later in the demo where I'm
running and I'm poison to my health
dropping and I squeeze through the crack
and I just get far enough away to
bandage myself up and that was awesome
to take it back a second and this might
be I don't know like a boring question
but to do a point about keeping up the
intensity and the original last of us
feeling like a puzzle and you know if
you fail the puzzle you kind of restart
the checkpoint what is checkpointing
like it seemed like keeping like that
intensity going how would you even find
a good point to take a playa back to now
of course this is pre preview code so it
seemed like it was based on like you're
like there's different not this is an
exact but like car loads of people right
so once I took out a section of car look
would these this group that I've done in
one area and I progressed to the next
thing because we're all trying to find
our thing was to try to get to Tommy and
there's like smoke in the distance so
we're winding through this neighborhood
have blown a house and all the stuff I'd
kill it one group ride or clear the one
group moving to the next and if they
killed me it would start me pretty much
from where I stopped the last group now
the thing about it was though that it
loaded instantly yeah you see this I
would die and it would come back and I
was like oh well so I I didn't even
notice it loaded that quick cuz it has
that tip screen it's like X to continue
and I thought I'd just been X for
another tip yeah and then I found I was
like oh actually it was just a tip
screen I don't know if that's vertical
slice stuff or if that's just for this
demo or whatever but it was like again
like those kinda I remember when you die
in a long stretch of the first
and like to get back into it immediately
it kept up the intensity of like alright
cool I gotta move on I gotta get these
people yeah the dogs were tricky too
made it tough that was the thing I'm
like I know that I'll learn a better way
to do this like actually I had it where
they were following my scent trailing I
was coming up on the dog is too did that
but even then I didn't get the normal I
didn't think kill command but it might
have been that they noticed me at the
last second I'm not sure there's so much
happening in that game sorry are they're
infected dogs nothing we saw yeah that
we saw no I was reading Phil's preview
that you can read on the aforementioned
Phil horn truck yeah and genuinely like
the things that excited me most and this
is very strange but like the fact that
the enemies have names I thought was
blew my mind but also the fact that you
don't have to craft SHIVs anymore yeah
yeah bring up to you can stealth kill
clickers now without having a shiv which
is kind of nice because especially on
grounded mode it's like you probably get
to SHIVs the entire game so it was kind
of like alright I guess I'm just
avoiding every single clicker I find but
yeah like you do feel a little bit and
that's the little stuff right of like I
you know I want to play last was again
before I get the last of us to it was
that idea that I'm like playing it and
the dodging and the jumping and then
yeah the Switchblade I wasn't even
thinking I mean like dodging and jumping
I guess I was but like the Switchblade
stuff I wasn't thinking about like oh
man this is quality of life improvement
that they've actually listened instead I
was thinking of like when I'm mailing
with the Switchblade eventually you know
I pick up a machete or hatchet I was
like oh this is much better way I forgot
about that
but mailing these people with the
switchblade is terrifying and horrifying
because you're like just swinging in
like he'll cut them on the cheek and
you'll see it on their cheek yeah the
game is grotesque in terms of his
violence yeah when I saw it at e3 I saw
like a behind closed doors thing at e3
2018 and it looked like you press a
button and there's a scripted sequence
like that's how personalized the comment
looked and then I asked about it in the
interview after and they were like no
that's none of that so yeah you're
tapping the button that's not that's
active so it seems like it's the X
button like when you get into some of
those tight spots or something like that
appease the cross button yeah
but it seems like when you get to some
of those tighter areas like if you just
hit the cross button I did you just go
right through it
and they were saying that the technology
that they've built for the animations I
probably will butcher this but but
basically they've created a bunch of
keyframes that can blend in with pretty
much anything you're doing at the time
so all your actions should feel pretty
smooth like you know sometimes in games
if you flip around quickly the
characters comic bounces back and forth
while other games you'd like to see the
character move around like this
the at least they were saying yeah
they've built a system where no matter
what you chained together it should
still look and feel pretty fluid right
so so what I was saying what I meant
what that was like yeah it's not like
all of these are like set actions that
led a ston your inputs
it's like dynamic House blown away by
that back then and then it sounds like
it is even more intense than I thought
yeah and I noticed like Naughty Dog has
been doing this for a while actually but
depending on where you kill someone the
animation can change and I saw a lot of
those especially with like when you pick
up a melee weapon like a machete or
hammer or something like if they're
against the wall it's pretty brutal if
your back is turned and you flip around
and swing it seemed it seemed different
so yeah it seems like there's it was a
lot and I know it sounds goofy but I
hadn't emotionally prepared for it where
it was that thing as I sat down and it
was that in the room of banning stuff
like I do not want to go back out there
I do not want to engage but you do
because it's like satisfying but you
don't because like I'm in that moment
with her like this is socks on kill me I
don't want those though okay Ellie swim
great question I you know I I didn't do
one of the interviews with Neal I didn't
do one neither with Neal
I guarantee many many an article
tomorrow will tell you house house
crafting has that changed all yes yeah
well you actually would be a better
source to me you played more or less of
us I think than I did I mean it's so
like on-the-fly it's still pretty much
the same right like you'll throw down
your backpack in craft but the one big
difference I noticed was with weapon
crafting and it's one thing Anthony
Newman I think the co-director pointed
out was that they kind of got rid of
like a traditional menu from here to
workbench instead like if you want to
upgrade
sniper rifle or whatever there'll be an
animation of le like pulling out the
bolt and like putting in a magazine like
she actually builds these guns in front
of you anywhere no no you happens pretty
fast but like it's it it's one of those
small things that I didn't even really
think about but seeing it there it makes
you feel so much more into the action
it's also kind of like it's a little I
don't know unsettling seeing le just
totally she took part in a couple
seconds in like she's like oh I can use
this to get more ammo and like load it
and put it back together within a couple
seconds and it's like I'm gonna use that
thing to kill a lot of people and you
just put that together in like three
seconds it's like what it's been five
years since the previous game right yeah
if I can trust this Instagram post from
14 to 19 so like at this point she's
like a stone-cold killer I'd imagine
yeah one of the things we haven't talked
about that I really really loved is
something you don't see a lot in
videogames is that uh oh the door is
locked right but if it's a pane of glass
next to it pick up a brick and throw it
through the glass or all through the
window like there and I you get in
that's how I got in like a pharmacy and
some other stuff so I was grabbing you
know the bolts all there that you need
for crafting the supplements now to go
and make you know better listen mode
stuff like that more health or whatever
I found it very satisfying to smash
those when totally yeah like they're
like you know you could just mail it and
I was like yeah but I want to throw a
brick through the window yeah it's the
end of the world man
what is the Friendly AI like phil was
kind of glowing when he was talking
about it cuz it's it actually feels like
you're AI companion has impact this time
I feel like Ellie when you play the
original lots of us especially issue is
just gals being pals like one of your
pals they can't do anything together
just be very very good friends exactly
totally don't worry ah yeah what I don't
when there was clickers there was a few
times where it would be like I went one
way she went the other and we both took
out you know clickers at the same time
yeah she wouldn't go like down and you'd
have to revive no no no it was it was
the same way of like the old times to
wear like a clicker would see like walk
over by her but
she wouldn't set him off apparently they
said they were working to try to make
that not happen as much but if you saw
it probably gonna happen here and
they're like how do you not let that
happen
yeah but we also only saw like the buddy
stuff in the first part which was pretty
easy and like I was friend of a tutorial
again for the first part it was mainly
like we're giving you story and you're
talking to her and feeling it out and
having these really cool emotional
moments with her like when you like
somebody and you're not sure if they
like you and you're like the feeling and
I'm like there's one point literally
were like all right use the toy the
trailer spoiled stuff for you all right
all right
you know they're not girlfriends that's
what that's what the trailer ends with
our whole thing was to just lay it out
of the table because I'm sure somebody
else is ruining in another preview
anyway like you you ride through the
morning after the kiss and you're acting
like nothing's happened and you're
talking about your exes and riding and
doing stuff and eventually the snowstorm
happens
you hole up in this place on the couch
and that's where that conversation of
like would you think our kiss last night
you know I mean like that's there's been
a buildup of a what are we doing and
what's happening in like - like oh
there's one part where like she said
something Deena says something at how he
tries to say something cool and it
doesn't work I'm so worried about Deena
getting fridge that's another thing as
when did you get any sense of what
happens to Deena
no no no yeah my my prediction is that
something very bad happens to her and
that's what sets Ellie off almost of
course but that might be too obvious
then that's the thing - is that like you
know the previous last was trailers last
was two trailers have led us to believe
that
Joel's the one that probably died and
Ellie's avenging Joel and so I I feel
like I don't put it past them to be
doing the same thing with this trailer
where oh Emily Miz actually this third
character that was their dog or whatever
now they're avenging the dog or whatever
yeah well I have a question for you
because we were talking about it today
on games daily and it's that kind of
thing like outside of our wheelhouse for
the most part right is there a way to do
that and not have it be just the trope
of fridge if we know more about Deena if
she's a well-rounded character does that
make sense or like yeah I think there's
a way to I mean honestly I think it
depends on the quality of the writing in
the execution like I think the first
last of us like Sarah is fridge right
like Joel's daughter so like that's
technically a fridging but which if you
don't know what fridging is it's like a
dead character but it's basically having
a character yeah just yeah that you've
barely fleshed out in any way shape or
form that you just killed to motivate
them usually male character right to go
forth and do something yes as made
famous by the kyle rayner Green Lantern
run exactly
then the subset of fridging would be
queer tragedy being like we're a lot of
queer stories and with heartbreak or
tragedy rather than being happy together
so those are two complicated things but
I mean I think that the first game
handles that well because Joel so
obviously uses Ellie as a surrogate for
his daughter who died and then that
becomes its own dynamic yeah I think it
has to do with the execution I think it
has to do with the character the
trajectory of the story the themes like
I don't have like a rulebook for it so I
think I think one thing to point out
which they also said to is that the
first one wasn't really a revenge story
necessarily like it kind of seems like
it could be that way because his
daughter dies but you know it's mostly
about it's about Joel and Ellie I'm
adopting a new dog exactly well they
said like upfront Neal was like this
game is about revenge and hate and how
closely that is how close how close that
can be associated with love yes I read
it's an old interview with Neil
druckmann where he talks about yeah the
theme of the first game is love the some
of this game is hey um so it's entirely
possible that that Deena something bad
happens to her or the dog or the dog you
never know but um I think knowing
Naughty Dog though like III think
blessing might be right though I have a
feeling like that my
speak to too obvious however there is a
poetic narrative purpose to repeating
themes from a previous you know like in
the sequel there's something poetic
about like this has all happened before
and it'll all happen again that was for
you so and I feel like the already
hinting at that and what we played right
because they are in a happy place
obviously as they're feeling about this
relationship and dealing with their
normal everyday and at one point Dean is
talking about this other guy she used to
run with who's passed away
and she's like oh yeah he's tell me
stories about how Tommy would do all
this stuff and I don't believe it like
bad stuff and I was like no I totally
believe it like Joel told me stories
about horrible things I had to do to
survive and so I do think that's going
to be you hope we write with Joel's
introduction at the end that the
narrative here is like listen kid like
you you know you don't have to do this
I've done this I've walked this path and
it doesn't fix it it doesn't they also
said which Phil mentioned to like the
Last of Us is called part 2 because it
is a or at least this is what Anthony
women told us during interviews it's not
called last Vista - it's it's called
last part - because it's very much a
continuation of the relationship between
Joel and Ellie so it sounds like like
those two characters are still gonna be
the main focus in their relationship -
so I think I think you're right or
probably be Joel being like maybe no you
listen it down like I've yeah I've done
this before
really I'm already tainted I can do it
for you kinds of shades you know lake
look at how Haggerty like skiing that's
gonna be the big part of it you watch
the trailer like in the we have an area
called the speed zone there's a petition
to rename it really the blast zone
because we were watching we watching
beyblade tournaments in there the other
day wait awesome veto blast zone Michael
hi I'm involved in this yes yeah of
course but we were watching trailer in
there
the first thing everybody said with
Joel's house he was like you look like
[ __ ] dude you don't like he looks old he
a Jalan five years so I didn't actually
watch the trailer and so transparency
it's Wednesday today and
I was on she wins Damon deeds I was on a
shoot yesterday and I was like I didn't
get home until late and I was like you
know what I'm not gonna watch this on my
phone I'm gonna watch this nice yeah I'm
gonna save it tomorrow I watched you
today and everyone else had already seen
it and was like doing their own thing
and I was thought that and then even
though I knew that Joel was gonna be in
it as soon as he appeared on screen I
would just motional moment damn I like I
love this game but I didn't realize just
how much I love yeah yes yeah I had the
same thing where when I when I first saw
Joel I wasn't expecting me expecting it
to hit me as hard as it did and when I
saw him and when they um I frickin there
was one line they said I cannot remember
but there was a certain line that happen
and I was like I got immediate chills
when he said I'm not gonna let you do
this alone yes yes and I was like oh
let's freakin go like white Morgan
Freeman like before we move on any last
words
last of us to questions comments
Callie's got one marijuana oh yeah yeah
so oh I guess yeah because I was part
4/20 I was I love that no I when I was
writing the story about I was assigned a
news story details article when the
trailer is happening and I was I had to
be like they are smoking what appears to
be a joint breaking movie I really
wanted to be like a marijuana cigarette
I really wanted to go all in but anyway
I had to say what appears to be because
it has not been confirmed